he took tuesday edition of pft ot the
one tuesday that feels like a monday
memorial day weekend behind us
summer unofficially has begun coming up
in just a couple of days chris the nfl
owners will get together again virtually
last week they didn't focus on potential
rule changes this week they will and one
of the proposals that is gaining
momentum
the alternative to the onside kick
because the kickoff formation as revised
by the nfl for safety reasons has made
it harder for teams to recover an
on-site kick they are suggesting the
possibility of twice per game
a team choosing to use a fourth and 15
play from their own 25 as an alternative
to the onside kick if you convert you
keep possession if you fail the other
team the team that would be the
receiving team takes possession at the
spot where your drive
ended we talked about this a little bit
during pft live but this is one that has
plenty of layers and levels the thing we
mentioned earlier today the idea that
you can use it even if you're not
trailing you can use it twice per game
whether you're ahead whether you're
behind or whether the game is tied i
don't like the possibility as we
mentioned during the show of a
mastermind like bill belichick who goes
up by four points with two seconds left
to play
instead of having to squib kick it and
maybe we get a stanford band type of a
play he can just have his quarterback
run around and run out of bounds and the
game is over i don't like that i i want
the team
that is ahead to have to kick the ball
off not do this fourth and 15 play if
they still have one of the two
opportunities in their bag chris yeah i
agree i would agree with you there i
mean that would be against the spirit of
the rule there to where they got to
maybe make this down untimed down right
i think realistically maybe that's how
you do it something like that that would
make the most sense you know i mean
listen i'm torn between this this new
rule or this you know rule proposal
i like it in some ways i understand that
it will bring excitement to the football
game uh i i understand that and from
that aspect hey i'm a fan and i want to
see that too but at the same time too
i think um there's a few things i'm
worried about you know one
i think the success rate of this type of
fourth and 15
is going to be greater than like what
the statistics show during seasons of
fourth and 15
uh numbers or whatever they might
compile the statistical averages i think
it's going to be better than that you
know for two reasons this is what you
know again the the quarterback and the
offense are gonna have to push the
envelope here they got to do it the
second thing is more times than not it's
gonna be the team that's trailing more
times than not they have just gone on a
long drive mike you've heard me complain
about this before
where now the defense is exhausted and
now they got to go out there for
again one of the biggest plays of the
game which i think again will lead to
maybe some sloppiness too on the
defensive side of the ball where you
know the the past interference things
like that all of those type of things
can happen to where that worries me a
little bit mike i think uh about the
competitive balance there's a part of me
hey listen there's a reason the team's
up by more than two or three scorers
they've dominated the football game and
i don't want to make it too easy to let
some team into the game late in the game
on these fourth and 15. so that's what i
worry about i guess
let me ask you this question because i
recently wrote about the fatigue factor
for the defense
thank you very much thank you the idea
that the defense has just been been
driven upon and given up a touchdown and
now they have to go back and defend this
fourth and 15 play if they fail they
have to stay out on the field the
pushback i got from some was well the
offense is going to be tired too the
offensive line is going to be tired as
well so it's a wash address that since
you played
well yeah
it's still not the same you know the
offensive line they don't need to have
the same intensity they get to work as a
group as far as four pass rushers are
concerned and things like that offenses
can pick certain plays too to give the
offensive line you know a break might be
a wide receiver screen or something like
that to where they can get the ball out
of the head hey receive or go run those
defensive linemen still got to go run
after that receiver and pursue them the
offensive alignment yeah they're going
to block downfield or try to do that but
it's a perceived almost play off that
way you know that it takes more energy
to play defense than offense it does
you're having to chase people on the
defensive side of the ball so you know
from that standpoint and you don't know
where you're going the offense knows
where they're going so there is a
difference there as far as the intensity
and emotions that need to be brought by
the defensive side of the ball mike and
hey there's that
and let me ask you this i mean
i feel like fourth and 15
favors the teams with the best
quarterbacks or the best passing
offenses and i'm not necessarily sure i
love that aspect of it too that's
another thing i want to talk to you
about
well you're right and it was patrick
mahomes who took to twitter once the
proposal came to light with a couple of
emojis that indicate he's delighted by
the possibility of a fourth and 15 play
in order to keep possession andy reid
the coach the chiefs has come out and
said i've got a quarterback who can
convert fourth and 15. let me tell you
something from my standpoint a guy who
plays a little bit of madden almost
every day the prospect of being able to
keep possession by converting fourth and
15. hell i go for fourth and 15 all the
time i converted one yesterday i got to
play for fourth and 15. i know how to do
it i mean my goodness it it really does
invite
um the risk-taking by the teams that
number one have a coach who is wired to
think that way but number two you have a
quarterback you feel good about and you
have a play that you've designed
specifically for fourth and 15. you know
how teams have a goal line package and
you know at times like one of the
reasons why
teams aren't successful on fourth and
long you don't practice fourth and long
you don't have a lot of fourth and long
plays well you know what now you know
i'm glad we're talking about this
because i've kind of tripped over
something here now you are going to have
fourth and 15 plays which is good
easier to convert four than 15. that's
what i was saying outside alternative
right that's why i was saying at the
start of the segment i think
statistically if we start to go down
that we're going to see more conversions
than what the the numbers would lead us
to believe maybe for the last 20 years
and fourth and 15 plus type because
you're right teams are going to take
more time to practice it now they're
going to develop more plays the other
thing i get concerned about too mike is
you know a quarterback throwing into
quadruple coverage right it's a horrible
decision he threw a jump up pass
interference on the defense what are you
talking about he just threw the ball
don't i worry about that
and
you know another thing too mike to what
you kind of just brought up
you know okay yeah patrick mahomes and
the chiefs
they're built to do that and certainly
have an advantage
you know i don't know is that as fair to
the baltimore ravens uh i'm sorry that's
my dog back there but is that is that
fair to do the baltimore ravens like to
me if you're gonna have a fourth and
fifteen maybe they should have some sort
of scenario where it's fourth and two
and you have to run the football right
to where like no you have to run it
maybe the four teams like the 49ers or
the ravens they might go hey i'm more in
favor of that than the fourth and 15
trying to throw with jimmy garoppolo or
an offense in baltimore that doesn't
have a ton of receivers that i trust and
we're not built like that i'm just
throwing it out there what do you think
well you know what i kind of like this
now how about this and and we're just
this was not planned we're just kind of
riffing here
what if the team
that would be kicking off and would be
using the onside kick
says we want to do the onside kick
alternative and then the defense chooses
whether it's fourth and fifteen or
whether it's fourth and two
and you have to run
right yeah and well and and it would be
fourth and two from the two where you
don't get 75 yards behind you you have
to worry about play action and patrick
mahomes throwing for a touchdown on that
play now look it quick quickly gets
convoluted and complicated but if we're
just talking about a way to retain
possession
i i want the defense to be able to force
the offense to run the ball and you
don't force them to run the ball unless
it's fourth and two from the two that's
why i throw that out there as a twist
but i like the idea that maybe the
defense gets to pick the match up if the
offense says we're gonna go with the
alternative the defense says well it's
either going to be fourth and 15
uh from the 25 or it's gonna be fourth
and goal from the two and if you convert
it you get it on your own thirty
okay
actually i hear you i'd rather have the
offense choose i would rather have it
that way um and then even if it was
fourth and two mike you can still do it
the normal spot you're just you're not
allowed to play action pass it has to be
a true running play not even like the
old like shovel pass or anything like
that nothing would be legal but to me
you know i think if you ask like lamar
jackson and the baltimore ravens with
their tight ends and their misdirection
run game they might feel more
comfortable about hey it's fourth and
two we're running the ball defense and
that's the way it is rather than fourth
and fifteen hey we're throwing the ball
they're a team that's built to run it
you know that's why it just says it
favors kansas city they have all the
tools and everything to make the fourth
and fifteen happen a lot better than
some other teams and to me you know it's
a little bit of a
unfair advantage i guess because you
don't build your team upon those
premises now right now it just happens
to be the best team in football
does have those premises but that's rare
that we don't always see that happen and
uh i i don't know it's just an
interesting angle to me at least so just
to just to summarize this because i like
the idea and i was thinking of it from
the standpoint of the defense getting to
to put the offense in the worst possible
spot you're saying let the offense put
itself in the best possible spot
if it's a passing team fourth and 15. if
you're not confident your ability to
convert fourth and 15 passing the ball
you surrender the ability to pass you
run it fourth and two and i think at
that point you would just put it on the
38 i think the line of demarcation still
needs to be the 40. that if you convert
you have the ball at or about the
40-yard line
heading toward the other end zone trying
to parlay that into a score so the
offense says we want we're going to use
the the onside kick alternative we
either get fourth and 15 and we can run
it or pass it or we get fourth and two
and we have to run it i kind of like
that
i i i think it's you know to me it just
it's it's a little more fair to the
teams that are building themselves on
hey we want to run the football and play
defense or do that and play that style
football or you know even for the
scenario let's just say you know you're
an average team in football and your
starting quarterback got hurt during the
game and now you're going man the fourth
and 15 we're just we can't convert that
not with this back up quarterback and oh
man our receivers out for the game you
know okay i like our chances and listen
fourth and two
when you tell the defense you have to
run the football
that is going i would bet you the
numbers would be close to what they are
at fourth and fifteen fourth and one
fourth and six inches against the
defense that has a good inkling that a
team's gonna run the football is hard
enough let alone two full yards i mean
that is that will be tough sledding and
like i said you got to keep that off
instead like no there's no forward pass
element anything like that it has to be
a true lateral or handoff or something
like that that fits within a you know
running attempt uh but it's just
something that popped to my brain a
little bit just what i thought was maybe
fair to some other teams in football
yeah and you know the other point that
i'll make i'm a big fan of just doing
fourth and 15 as the replacement for
the the kickoff altogether because out
of that that play
you can put your punt team on the field
and you surrender possession that way
you punt it now i know they still have
separate safety concerns about the punt
play but not the same level they have
about the kickoff play so you go fourth
and 15 send out the punter you punt it
you run a fake punt which becomes uh the
simulation of the surprise onside kick
right you can run a fake punt out of
punt formation on fourth and 15. you
keep possession it's just like
recovering the onside kick that no one
expects the beginning of the third
quarter of super bowl 44 is the best
example of that you can put your offense
out on the field and go for it or you
can put your your quarterback out there
in shotgun formation and he can pooch
punt it like we've seen guys like ben
roethlisberger and randall cunningham do
so i i just i like that as the
overall replacement for the kickoff
there's been talk about that the
commissioner first raised it back in
2012. it was a great shiano idea
that was a result of the the uh eric
legrand tragedy at rutgers and i just i
feel like it i feel like this is a step
toward possibly having that happen chris
yeah i hear you i mean there's got to be
something done you're right i mean you
know again we did see some success with
these onside kicks towards the end of
the year but you know i think it is it's
too few and far between i don't know if
we can anybody who's realistically
watches football can sit there and go oh
i think the offense can get a little
more consistent in recovering these
onside kicks or whatever it may be i
think the ones we saw that were
successful at the end of the year
there's a little bit of you know luck a
fortuitous bounce you know i do think
the kickers figured it out uh but you
know
again i understand it wanting to be
changed i do i honestly i think i'd want
to give it one more year mike of the way
it is before we did this just because i
i really feel like the the kickers got
an idea of how they wanted to kick the
ball with this new
uh formula not to like halfway point of
the season so there's a part of me that
just would like to see it go one more
year um but if it did the fourth and 15
you know i'm not gonna hate it i just
got some questions about it
but if it's gonna come down to some
combination of skill and luck i'd rather
the skill and luck be
normal football play not can the kicker
devise some funky way to make the ball
bounce into the air and do you get lucky
when it careens off of richard rogers
shoulder pads or something like that i'd
rather that all play out in the confines
of a traditional scrimmage play but you
know it feels like something is moving
in that direction and they need to have
a more effective way to let the team
that is trailing be
relevant keep the game interesting right
i mentioned this on friday when we
discussed it with big cat chris the the
idea that roger goodell said several
years ago when he was asked who does he
root for he said the team that's behind
right because they want the game to be
exciting and they want the team that's
trailing to have a chance to come back
and tie the game and win it and and i
think they're on the right track i say
get rid of that option if you're leading
i don't like it there
um and uh and maybe we'll give it a try
for years a one year experiment let's
see just like past interference replay
review one year 24 votes to try it for a
year and it's going to take 24 votes to
do it again not 24 votes to kill it i
think it's worth a shot um because that
the onside kick
recovery rates by the kicking team are
just too low
to to keep the games interesting late
yeah i i hear you you know but it's not
a that's not my favorite point of this
you know again
you know there's a reason one team is
you know up by 20 points with three
minutes left on the board they've done
you know they've dominated the game they
deserve to win i don't want just like oh
oh now this other team came back because
they made four plays like that that's
what i worry about a little bit i do so
i i i don't think i would see a
pre-season experiment with it a little
bit first before we actually put it into
the regular season so i'm more in favor
and let's toy with it this preseason if
we do have it and then start to
reevaluate it from there because to what
troy vincent said about the past
interference thing there was unintended
consequences that they did not foresee
happening and things that went on and i
think this could be one of those things
too to where you know let's evaluate a
little bit think about it a little bit
more and then if we like in the
preseason maybe we put it in the 20 20
21 season
we'll find out on thursday whether or
not the owners will approve this
proposal and put the onside kick
alternative in play for 2020. that's it
for today's pftot we'll be back on
wednesday with another edition of pft
live chris have a great day we'll see
everybody
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports